[Musik]
grausiger fund im frachtcontainer in der
nähe von london entdeckten polizeibeamte
die leichen von 39 menschen ein mann
wird festgenommen
umstrittener plan für nordsyrien die
verteidigungsministerin erläutert ihr
konzept für eine sicherheitszone
auch der koalitionspartner spd ist nicht
überzeugt
langsamer abschied von der ölheizung das
bundeskabinett will neue anlagen ab 2026
nur noch in ausnahmefällen und
finanzielle anreize schaffen für den
umstieg
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers und narben an diesem
mittwoch zum nachrichtenüberblick aus
der heute redaktion sport nachher in der
sendung mit kristin otto sehr gerne
einen schenkel amt mitten in der nacht
wird die britische polizei den ort grace
östlich von london gerufen
in einem lastwagen findet sie 39
menschen tot
wer sie sind und was genau geschah ist
noch nicht klar aber erinnerungen werden
wach an 2015 als 71 flüchtlinge in einem
kühllaster in ungarn erstickten im jahr
zuvor konnten 34 afghanen im englischen
hafen tilbury kurz vor dem verdursten
aus einem schiffscontainer gerettet
werden andreas stamm ein industriegebiet
vor den toren londons ein abgestellter
laster ein grausiger fund in der nacht
nach einem notruf entdecken die
rettungskräfte 39 leichen in anhänger
des lkw der fahrer ein mann aus
nordirland 25 jahre alt wurde unter
mordverdacht festgenommen
zu diesem zeitpunkt wissen wir nichts
über die identität und die herkunft der
opfer
das dürfte ein längerer prozess der lkw
hier auf bildern einer
überwachungskamera aus der nacht seien
bulgarien zugelassen so die polizei
weiter
und war für die firma einer irischen
eigentümerin unterwegs so weit momentan
rekonstruierbar soll der anhänger in der
nacht vom belgischen zeebrügge ins
britische perfid verschifft worden sein
einem hafen nahe des fundorts grace in
der grafschaft essex dort sei er mit der
zugmaschine verkuppelt worden
wie lange die menschen im anhänger waren
wofür sie die fahrt begann aus welchen
gründen dazu konnte die polizei noch
nichts sagen im parlament zeigt sich der
premierminister schockiert das britische
unterhaus vereint in seltener eintracht
eine unvorstellbare tragödie die an das
herz bricht die gedanken und gebete
aller im parlament sind bei denen die
angehörige verloren haben viele menschen
tot in einem lkw anhänger
ob es sich bei den opfern wie bei
vergleichbaren fällen in ganz europa um
flüchtlinge handelt das steht im
mittelpunkt der ermittlungen ebenfalls
nicht ausgeschlossen menschen handelt
beispielsweise in rotlicht
die untersuchung wird tage dauern
während die toten am abend im lkw an
einen anderen ort gebracht werden
fernab der öffentlichkeit um die würde
der opfer zu wahren
die entwicklung im norden von syrien hat
jetzt auch eine neue dimension die in
deutschland spielt seit die
bundesverteidigungsministerium eine
internationale mission dort
vorgeschlagen hat annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat heute ein paar details
dazu bekannt gegeben
es soll er einen uno einsatz werden auch
mit kampftruppen
ihre idee ist aber nach wie vor
umstritten wie hirscher annegret kramp
karrenbauer macht immer noch
antrittsbesuche bei der truppe heute in
erfurt sie ist noch keine 100 tage im
amt
ihr vorschlag für eine sicherheitszone
in nordsyrien hat ihr viel
aufmerksamkeit eingebracht und auch viel
kritik dagegen setzt sie sich zur wehr
und präzisiert ihre idee in einem punkt
sie erst einmal geht es um einen impuls
um einen prozess nach vorne zu treiben
ein prozess der idealerweise enden
sollte in einem mandat der vereinten
nationen un in einer mission die auch
von den vereinten nationen geführt wird
ob es am ende zu dieser lösung kommen
wird kann im moment keiner garantieren
welche rolle die bundeswehr in einem un
einsatz haben könnte lässt die
ministerin weiterhin offen
außenminister maß drängt auf konkrete
antworten kramp-karrenbauer müsse jetzt
liefern sagen auch die abgeordneten im
verteidigungsausschuss denen die
ministerin am morgen ihre vorschläge
erläutert hat wenn es darum geht
festzulegen wie so etwas überhaupt
konkret gestalt annehmen könnte könnte
dann kursieren im öffentlichen raum
zahlen von einem personal ansatz von bis
zu 40.000 soldatinnen und soldaten die
erforderlich wären um eine solche
sicherheitszone überhaupt zu tragen kam
karrenbauer wenn ihren vorschlag morgen
hier in brüssel mit ihren nato kollegen
diskutieren
der generalsekretär bewertet den vorstoß
aus deutschland nicht
ich begrüße das alliierte vorschläge
haben wie eine politische lösung
gefunden
für ein un-mandat wie kramp karrenbauer
ist vorschlägt braucht es die zustimmung
von russland und nach der sieht es im
augenblick nicht aus und dann gucken wir
jetzt auf die situation im norden von
syrien wo russland und die türkei jetzt
gemeinsam die kontrolle übernehmen
wollen diesen koordinierten
militäreinsatz hatten die präsidenten
beider staaten ausgehandelt und heute
sind bereits russische militär
patrouillen zu sehen
die russisch türkische vereinbarung
beraubt die kurden ihre hoffnung auf
eine autonome region sie hatten vor
kurzem noch ein drittel des syrischen
staatsgebietes kontrolliert christoph
festival hier waren die kurden jetzt
sind wir da
türkische soldaten und ihre verbündeten
stehen auf einem ehemaligen kurdischen
hauptquartier deutlicher zeigen kann man
es nicht die säuberung im grenzstreifen
läuft allerdings nach einem plan der
nicht nur die kurdischen kämpfer trifft
sondern auch frauen kinder alte fast 180
tausend menschen mussten fliehen
zum beispiel in diese schule
landeinwärts eine mutter erzählt wie das
war als die türkischen angriffe losgehen
wir saßen zu hause ganz ruhig plötzlich
berühmten der flugzeuge zwei tage
irgendwie rum schliefen auf der straße
bis seiner sagte
da gibt es diese schule in hasaka jetzt
sind wir hier vertreibung und hunderte
tote
keine frage die kurden sind die großen
verlierer dieser krise die andere seite
zwei gewinner der russische und der
türkische präsident reichen sich die
hand nachdem sie allein gestern
festgelegt haben wie es weitergehen soll
im krisengebiet
demnach müssen die kurdischen kämpfer
jetzt doch fast den gesamten
grenzstreifen zur türkei räumen
tun sie es wirklich das sollen zunächst
syrische und russische einheiten
sicherstellen
nach sechs tagen übernehmen dann
türkische und russische soldaten die
patrouillen und noch ein gewinner
syriens machthaber assad seine armee
darf wie gesagt mit kontrollieren an der
grenze und sein staatsgebiet bleibe auf
jeden fall unangetastet verspricht
russland am frühen abend an meldet sich
der dessen truppenabzug den türkischen
angriffe nordsyrien überhaupt erst
möglich gemacht hat us-präsident
kampling kurven gs gut lässt er wissen
und erdogans waffenruhe halte deswegen
habe ich
veranlasst alle sanktionen gegen die
türkei aufzuheben
derweil fahren im grenzstreifen russen
und syrer bereits gemeinsam die straßen
ab um zu sehen ob wirklich alle kurden
kämpfer weg sind eben genau nach plan
was die usa der westen die nato dazu
sagen das spielt hier keine rolle
und wie geht es nun mal live zu jörg
brase auf türkischer seite in der nähe
der grenze zu syrien jörg guten abend
bleibt denn den kunden noch eine wahl
also noch hat die kurdische seite nicht
reagiert auf dieses russisch türkische
abkommen von gestern man berät sich wohl
noch aber man hat sicherlich angst davor
dass man die relative autonomie im
norden syriens verlieren könnte
dass es die zivile seite des problems
dann gibt es noch eine militärische die
kurdische gpg miliz hat zwei optionen
zum einen dass sie sich integrieren in
die syrische armee das hätte sicherlich
einige vorteile wäre aber wohl nicht so
einfach zu organisieren oder dass man
den bewaffneten kampf wieder aufnimmt
aber da stehen natürlich mit der
türkischen armee und auch mit russland
das ja darauf besteht dass sich die
kurdische miliz aus dem grenzstreifen
zurückzieht zwar übermächtige gegner
gegenüber zwar hat die spd führung heute
behauptet dass man sicherheitsgarantien
der amerikaner hätte aber die gab es
wohl nur um die milizen dann zum rückzug
zu bewegen also allzu viele
wahlmöglichkeiten hat die kurdische
seite nicht und deshalb sind sie
tatsächlich die verlierer der
entwicklungen der letzten zwei wochen
york vielen dank für diese analyse und
so fiel zunächst zu diesem thema in den
usa bringt ein top-diplomat den
präsidenten in erklärungsnot william
taylor dass der amerikanische
botschafter in der ukraine war in einer
vertraulichen anhörung des kongresses
und hat dort gesagt donald trump habe
beim ukrainischen präsidenten wolodimir
selensky sehr wohl us-militärhilfe
abhängig gemacht von ermittlungen gegen
den demokratischen
präsidentschaftsbewerbers joe biden und
dessen sohn
das hatte trump immer bestritten in
sachen bracket guckt die britische
regierung heute nach brüssel wo
diskutiert wird ob der austritt der
briten aus der union wieder einmal
verschoben wird womöglich bis ende
januar
eu rats chef donald tusk und
parlamentspräsident david soli haben
sich bereits dafür ausgesprochen
gestern abend hatte premierminister
boris johnson im unterhaus eine
niederlage erlebt obwohl das parlament
grundsätzlich für seinen braig set plan
gestimmt hatte wurde seinen zeitplan für
die austritts gesetze abgelehnt
ein geregelter brachse zum 31 oktober
ist damit so gut wie unmöglich
zurück nach deutschland wo sich für uns
alle einiges ändern wird beim thema
heizen aber zum beispiel auch beim
tanken denn das kabinett hat weitere
teile des klimapakets beschlossen
schauen wir uns an punkt 1 der preis auf
klimaschädliches co2 ab 2021 zum start
erst mal zehn euro pro tonne
heißt konkret einen liter benzin wird
etwa drei cent teurer
punkt 2 es sollen ab 2026 keine
ölheizungen mehr neu eingebaut werden
allerdings gibt es ausnahmen und geld
vom staat wenn man auf eine
klimafreundlichere heizung umsteigt mehr
jetzt von andreas ruppert tim schröder
in seinem element
der schornsteinfegermeister prüft die
abgaswerte eine heizanlage dass die
bundesregierung künftig den einbau von
ölheizungen schritt für schritt
eindämmen will
für ihn ein schwieriges unterfangen da
wo es keine leitungsgebundenen
energieträger gibt im ländlichen raum da
wird deutlich schwerer auf das öl zu
verzichten
das bundeskabinett hat heute das neue
gebäude energie gesetz auf den weg
gebracht darin festgeschrieben auch ein
künftiger ein baustopp für ölheizungen
von einem verbot will der
wirtschaftsminister nicht treten sie
können sagen es ist ein verbot mit
erlaubnis möglichkeit mit ausnahmen
dann ist es aber kein striktes verbot es
wird aber dazu führen davon bin ich
überzeugt dass wir in rund 80 bis 90
prozent der fälle keine ölheizungen mehr
installieren werden ab 20 26 soll heizöl
als wärmelieferant der vergangenheit
angehören das an den alten ölbrenner
austausch und sich für eine
klimafreundlichere heizungs variante
entscheidet soll 40 prozent der
anschaffungskosten als prämie erhalten
effektive klimapolitik sieht anders aus
für
die grünen die bundesregierung will
einfach noch in heizungen bis mitte des
nächsten jahrzehnts einbauen lassen die
dann jahrzehntelang im betrieb sind
damit treiben sie die menschen in ein
heizsystem rein dass am ende nicht klima
gerecht ist und auch tim schröder ist
sich sicher dass er in den nächsten
jahren noch etliche ölheizungen
begutachten muss so stellen sie sich
zwei schüler vor gleiches alter gleiche
klasse gleiche schulformen und doch
trennen sie welten ein grund kann der
standort ihrer schule sein denn lernende
in einem sozial starken umfeld haben in
deutschland einen wissensvorsprung von
bis zu fünf jahren
schüler in sozialen brennpunkten zu
unterstützen das hat sich ein
förderprogramm zur aufgabe gemacht jetzt
gestartet von bund und ländern an arendt
und daniel pontzen diese bremer schule
war brennpunktschule gewalt drogen
unterirdische leistungen heute ist sie
eine vorzeigeschule in dieser achten
klasse loben und kritisieren die schüler
einander organisieren projekte und
lernen nach individuellen wochenplänen
ergebnis eines förderprogramms des
bremen 2005 startete das wichtige ist
dass wir uns über die landesgrenze
hinweg informieren konnten bei anderen
schulen uns bestimmte konzepte anschauen
konnten dass das gefördert wurde durch
mittel die wir nicht selber aufbringen
mussten
genau solche wandlungen deutschlandweit
sind ziel der bund länder initiative
schule macht stark wissenschafter sollen
hierzu mit praktikern gemeinsam konzepte
erarbeiten man zunächst 200 schulen und
25 millionen euro stehen hierfür bereit
laufzeit 10 jahre
er habe ich eine schule wo ich sag mal
dass sprachprobleme im vordergrund steht
oder habe ich eine schule wo es eben
vielleicht auch ganz andere kulturelle
probleme miteinander gibt und deswegen
brauchen wir ganz individuell für die
schulen auch sehr unterschiedliche
instrumente zum beispiel entlastung für
klassenlehrer damit die sich stärker
ein persönliches der schüler kümmern
können beratungsteams die in den
unterricht gehen und tipps geben sowie
elternlotsen die die oft passive
elternschaft enger an die schule binden
und wie etwa in hamburg erprobt wir
haben versucht schule mir zur heimat zu
machen
dazu gehören nicht nur baumaßnahmen die
die schule auch und baulich
anspruchsvoller werden lassen sondern
auch der deutliche ausbau des
verpflegungsangebot mit frühstück und
allem drum und dran
ein solches bündel führte auch in bremen
zum erfolg grundsätzlich muss eine
bereitschaft von kollegium vorhanden
sein sich auf einen neuen weg zu machen
dieser weg führte hier letztes jahr 42
prozent der zehntklässler an ein
gymnasium nach der vierten klasse hatten
nur drei prozent eine empfehlung hierfür
halten sehr wichtiges thema wichtig
natürlich auch der sport christin
fußball-champions-league woche und der
fc bayern münchen hatte seine bisher
längste serie von jetzt elf
auswärtsspielen nacheinander in der
königsklasse ohne niederlage fortgesetzt
3 zu 2 bei olympiakos piräus 1 erfolg
der aber nicht nur freude auslöste
strahlende sieger sind die bayern nicht
nach ihrem auftritt gegen piräus
gewonnen ja aber nicht überzeugend ich
glaube nicht dass die leistung die wir
heute abend gebracht haben am ende des
tages uns in diesem jahr große erfolge
bescheren wird wenn wir nicht die kurve
langsam kriegen die letzten elf minuten
heißt es zittern um den sieg als gerne
mit glück zum anschlusstor kommt die
gegentreffer quote
der kritikpunkte an diesem abend wie
wichtig thomas müller für die bayern ist
zeigt die tatsache dass er an beiden
treffern von robert lewandowski
beteiligt ist
nach niklas süle fällt mit lukas ein
weiterer verteidiger mit innenbandanriss
möglicherweise langfristig aus sieg und
tabellenführung mit bitteren
beigeschmack
bayer leverkusen droht dagegen nach der
dritten niederlage das frühe aus beim
zehnmaligen spanischen meister atletico
madrid verlor die bayer elf durch diesen
treffer in der 78 minute vom kurz zuvor
eingewechselten álvaro morata 0 zu 1 und
nachher tritt borussia dortmund bei
inter mailand an rb leipzig spielt
bereits gegen zenit st petersburg
enttäuschende wm test für die deutschen
handballerinnen sie kamen beim
länderspiel in kroatien nicht über 1 21
zu 21 hinaus und die partie der männer
beim olympiasieger in zagreb von 19 uhr
30 anzeigen wie im livestream in der zdf
mediathek die betrages rechte der
fußball-europameisterschaft zentrum wird
2024 in deutschland hat die telekom
erworben
um möglichst alle fußballfans zu
erreichen will das
kommunikationsunternehmen sub lizenzen
verkaufen
zdf-intendant thomas bellut sagte unser
interesse die em 2024 in irgendeiner
form im programm zu haben besteht weiter
wir bleiben für gespräche mit den neuen
rechteinhabern offen
die spiele der deutschen mannschaft
werden aber auf jeden fall frei
empfangbar sein
und christin wir bleiben noch ein
kleiner moment beim fußball der sc
freiburg baut ein neues modernes stadion
ab nächster saison sollen die heimspiele
hier stattfinden
der neubau ist auch ganz gut im zeitplan
aber jetzt hat ein gericht im
eilverfahren entschieden dass abends und
sonntagmittag dort nicht gespielt werden
darf
zuviel lärm für die nachbarn bei der
baugenehmigung wurde das offenbar
übersehen
die freiburger fußballer warten jetzt
auf das endgültige urteil und hoffen
dass sie ihr lärm berühmtes teilzeit
stadion doch noch richtig in der
bundesliga einsetzen können
die lotto 2 die gewinnzahlen lauten 17
16 19 26 31 und die superzahl 5
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
das wetter sonne nebel wolken und katja
hall im vergleich heute journal mit dem
kollegen claus kleber 21 uhr 45
morgens sind wir wieder für sie da vom
gesamten heute team danke fürs interesse
und ihnen allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren typisch
für den herbst sind unwetter tiefs am
mittelmeer das mittelmeer hat jetzt zum
teil noch temperaturen von über 20 grad
wenn dann kalte luft aus norden
heranzieht sind das genau die richtigen
voraussetzungen für solche unwetter
teams die dann hunderte liter regen pro
quadratmeter bringen können
typisch für den herbst ist allerdings
auch der nebel den wir heute in
deutschland ganz verbreitet hatten schon
am frühen morgen konnte man zum beispiel
auf der schwäbischen alb oder auch im
schwarzwald schon die sonne auf den
berggipfeln sehen und das nebelmeer
wurde immer dünner und das nebel gebiet
kleiner nicht überall löst sich der
nebel auf und jetzt in der nacht bildet
er sich gleich wieder neu bei 10 bis 4
grad und morgen geht es dann erst mal
wieder mit nebel und hochnebel los auf
den bergen strahlt aber schon von
anbeginn wieder die sonne am nachmittag
sollte sich der nebel häufig auflösen
denn der wind nimmt etwas zuge kommt aus
südlichen richtungen von nord westen
werden die wolken allerdings dichter die
temperaturen liegen morgen an der see
bei 15 bis 17
im binnenland bei 17 bis 24 grad in den
nächsten tagen geht es mild weiter an
der see droht sturm und erst am sonntag
wird es merklich kühler
schönen abend noch